the set data structure is kind of like
an array except there are no duplicate
items and the values are not in any
particular order the typical use for a
set is to simply check for the presence
of an item I'm going to show you how to
implement a set function bf6 actually
has a built in set object however the
built in set object does not contain all
the methods that are common to sets so
you may still have to implement part of
the set yourself depending on what
you're gonna use it for when I show you
the implementation for the set I will
tell you which methods are part of the
es6
set and which are not so we're just
gonna go through this code we're gonna
call it my set now we could call it set
but I want to make it different than the
es6 set so this is my set so here's just
the collection this set is gonna be a
collection of items and we're gonna
store them in an array which an array
can have duplicate items but we're gonna
implement this in such a way that you
cannot add duplicate items to this array
this method the method has is going to
check for the presence of an element and
then return true or false so we're gonna
pass in the element and it's going to do
collection that index of element is not
negative one so if the element is not in
the collection it's gonna return
negative one so if it doesn't return
negative one it's true so if it's not
negative one it's true that means the
element is in the array else it's false
now we have the values this is going to
return all the valleys of the set pretty
straightforward just return the
collection now I've add we're gonna add
an element to this set but first we have
to check if the Elm is in the set
already so we're gonna call the the
method we've already defined that has
method and see if the collection has the
element if it does not have the element
then we can add it we're gonna push that
element to that collection array and
we're gonna return true else we're gonna
return false so if we don't push an
element to the collection we're
returning false now we have removed this
is going to remove an element so first
way to check if the element is in
the collection and if it is in the
collection we're gonna find out what the
index other element is and then we're
gonna remove it splice is means we're
gonna take out we're gonna take out an
element in the array starting at the
index of the element and going for one
element we're gonna take out one element
and then we're gonna return true or
we're gonna return false if that element
is not in the collection then we're just
going to return the size of the
collection we're just going to turn
collections out link every method we've
gone through so far is in the es6
implementation of the set so the es6 set
has values add remove in size except
remove is delete in the ex6 set instead
of calling remove you're gonna call
delete but all the other things are
included another thing is size is not a
method in the es6 set size is a property
that just means that when you're calling
it you're not going to put parentheses
if after the the method because it's
just a property so you can do set that
size and sort of set that size with
parentheses after it okay now we're
going to get into the methods that are
not in the es6 implementation of the set
but are often included in sets the next
few methods actually just help you work
with sets and when you're working with
two different sets so we have the Union
this method is going to return the union
of two sets so it's gonna combine the
sets but leave out any duplicates in the
combination of the sets so we're gonna
call the Union method on the original
set we're gonna pass in the other set
that we want to combine we're gonna
create a new set which this should be my
set same with down here because we want
to make it distinct from the es6 set so
we have the the Union set which is just
a new set that's what we're going to
combine the sets into with the first
step which is this stop values and the
values were just calling the the values
method up here to return the collection
and the second set is going to be the
other set that values for a new first
set for each and for each value in that
set we're gonna do a union set that add
to add the value then we do the same
thing second set dot for each and for
each value in the second set we're going
to add the value remember the add method
already does not add the value if it's a
duplicate so the Union set now will not
contain any duplicates and since for the
set data structure the order doesn't
matter we don't have to have the values
in any particular order and then we're
going to return the Union set now we
have intersection which is going to
return the intersection of the two sets
as a new set so we're going to make a
new set here intersection set equals new
night set the first set again we're
going to call the dis to get all the
values in the first set
now for each value in the first set we
are going to check if the other set has
the value we are going to add it and
then we're going to return the
intersection set so the intersection is
just all the items that are in both sets
and that's we're gonna return that as a
new set and this next function we're
also gonna have to add them my there so
this is the difference so the difference
between the sets so all the items that
are in one set but not the other set so
we're gonna create a new set again the
different set and again we're gonna get
the values of the first step now this is
very similar to the intersection we're
going to go through each value in the
first set and if the other set does not
have the value up here we were seeing
it's the other set hand the value now
we're gonna use the not operator the
exclamation point to see if the value is
not in the set and we're going to add
that to the different set then we'll
return the different set and the last
method we're gonna taco is the subset
and this is going to test if the set is
a subset of a different set so to a test
if the first set is completely contained
within the second set so it's just gonna
return true or false so we're gonna pass
in the other set we're gonna again get
all the values of the first set and
we're going to call this function first
set that every and what that every
method is going to do is going to test
whether all the elements in the array
pass the tests implemented by the
provided function so we're gonna test it
all the elements in the first set we'll
pass this function which is other set
that has value are all the elements in
the first set are they in the second set
so we're gonna see if if the first set
is a subset of the second set so that's
the set data structure and let's quickly
just show you some some uses of the set
so we have set a it's not new my set set
B is new my set we're going to add to
set a a look at set B B when I edit set
BC or ad to set B a and we're going to
add to set B D and now we're gonna see
if set a is a subset of set B so is set
a is every item and set a which is
actually just the letter a and set B
which it is because it's right here
let's run that and it should say true
let's do some other things okay and this
is the set a that intersection set B is
going to return a new set which we're
then going to call the values function
so we can see all the values in that set
and it's just a because the only value
that's in both set a and set B is a but
we can do a lot of the same things with
the built in set I'm gonna copy all disk
instead of long that's my set or just
going to be half set we're gonna do set
C and set D
[Music]
okay so here's one difference with the
es6 set is that when you call the values
method instead of returning an array
it's going to return an iterator so you
can see objects set iterator here and
then you can still iterate through all
the items in the array besides that all
the other methods that a set has are
very similar to the mat the set that we
implemented so we can do set D delete
now this is instead of remove so we're
gonna delete the a and then we're going
to cancel that log and check if that D
has a and we can see it's false because
it's been deleted and we can also try to
add D which is already in the set oh and
there is one final thing that's
different with the es6 implementation
the add method is not gonna return true
or false whether the item has been added
or not besides adding the item what its
gonna return so what it's gonna cancel
that log is is the set itself it's not
an array of the set it's going to return
the full set so if we run that you can
see here it's going to return the set
which is an object and since it's an
object it's not gonna show all the
different items in the set okay that's
the set data structure thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good